is the thief of joy
which is 100 like like because a lot of
times even in the manuscript we talk
about stuff like you can't really change
like we'll talk about like a guy being
short and how he can't get as many girls
but what are you going to do change your
height or like a woman's age like what
am i going gonna do get younger and i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be real so my last
boyfriend was
a short king and i was like it didn't
stop me from being in a relationship
with him but if i'm being honest i
wanted to i wanted to talk i wanted a
toilet boyfriend and i know that's toxic
masculinity and i know that's all the
power is it toxic it's not it's your
biology
it's like it's not toxic and that's what
like we call these things toxic that
just are and we try to say like but
they're toxic to men because then short
men are like i'm not i'm not good enough
why yeah but like
you can't call it toxic when it's
biology it's just it's the same thing
with like
men being turned off by fat girls yeah
but so then it is toxic to the
individual experiencing it so a fat girl
is like i feel unattractive i hate my
life i'm not worthy i'm not valuable
yeah so a short guy that's the benefit
is my last boyfriend he was actually
very comfortable he was like i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah but i was like i also
have like i said i love being made to
feel tiny so i did yeah i don't
intentionally date tall guys i dated him
he didn't like when i wore heels and i
was like respectfully that's a you
problem i'm gonna wear heels like if
you're comfortable enough you're
comfortable enough but i was like yeah
i'd be alive i said i didn't wish you
were taller and made me feel tiny i just
don't really going back to the toxic
thing i just i get i don't i don't think
it's toxic it just is it's like like
that's life and life has some fat life
has some facts that aren't pleasant yeah
and we can't if we just say oh it's
toxic like they shouldn't exist they do
exist well that's right
and that's a really healthy ego yeah i'm
a big fan of ego so if you're if you're
secure that's it my ex he was like i'm
five foot six yeah and he was like i
literally don't give a [ __ ] but he did
give a [ __ ] when i wore heels but there
are some people who are like well cause
he can't he can't do anything about it
might as well just like get jacked and
make the most money he can and finally
actually they can they've got those uh
they've got those shoe fillers for guys
out there now
if you need it you've got some shoeflips
so if you're a guy if you're under five
nine just find yourself some shoe
fullers they get them all the time which
i feel like well i'm six one so i'm like
like you're helping out the competition
what's going on
okay i have a question right i get what
you mean about toxic yeah right like
things that come naturally to us yeah
even if they're unpleasant truths yeah
doesn't mean we should label them toxic
what would you see
as toxic behavior and why would you
label that as toxic as opposed to some
of the things we've talked about toxic
gaslighting like making someone question
their reality okay i'd say that's toxic
it's a form it's a form of manipulation
right yeah like manipulation like is
manipulation not part of
has not been part of human history
throughout could you not argue that
trying to manipulate to get what you
want in life is actually part of the
human condition oh it absolutely is you
read the 48 laws of power i haven't
known
really oh that's a really big yeah it
talks about like the
tactics people have used over the course
of human history to like get to power
right yeah so that's so essentially
manipulation is almost part of our
biology
yeah probably so why is that toxic then
why is it i would say that behavior is
toxic
like one is just like a fact one's a
behavior
like women are not attracted to short
men that's just that just is yeah one's
a behavior and something you're doing
and you know just because like it
happens like
so has you know genocide yeah
like there are people there are power
you know power can be used for good or
evil not every form of manipulation is
bad so i guess the toxic is
it's only toxic when there's a choice
involved
so you can't help who you're attracted
to yeah so you can't help being
attracted to tall guys yeah so that's
it's not toxic but you can choose
whether you want to manipulate someone
so that's toxic behavior yeah i mean
yeah i guess yeah you can choose
somewhere i don't have to think about
that more that's not expected but it's
kind of like i don't know there is
there's good and bad you know what i
mean like
you can there's manipulation tactics
that aren't that's really subjective in
itself like um i'm a very anti that's it
one i've had a relationship with a gas
lighter who like pretended to have
cancer and genuinely ruined my life but
um this is like to him he was in the
right and there's a poem okay this is so
nerdy but there's a poem and it's about
a um
a nazi who worked at bergen-belsen like
one of the concentration camps it's like
that's
objectively a bad thing but he came home
and he read stories to his children and
he button sweets so to them he's a good
person and so it's like that that
subjectivity of like and so gaslighters
will literally think that they're not
bad and you're there like to everyone
else and this is this really relates to
people who stay in abusive relationships
as well
and i have stayed in a lot of abusive or
disrespectful situations
where i'm like if a friend came to me
and went this is what i'm going through
i'd be like
are you are you confused you're being
disrespected but then when i'm in it i'm
like well it's because you're attracted
the same traits that make a man
successful are the same traits that make
a man evil so you're attracted to the
same thing
so it's like disagreeableness that like
they tend to make more money but if
you're disagreeable you also could go to
prison
and then it's like so is it
if there are any good successful men out
there who are kind yeah hit me up well
but the problem is you have to compete
for those guys so you know do you know
the stat where 80 if you ask 80 of women
what they want in a man they'll list 20
of men so the reason we hate man is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones oh and i know there's a there's oh
i know there's that statistic to be with
like
oh i can't remember it i think you told
me it and it was like the top percentage
of women one like women want to sleep
with the top percentage of men but men
are happy to sleep with
like but
whatever that's going to be that's
everyone that's what it's called but
that's what happened with the birth
control pill so the reason like actions
have consequences normally right so
normally
you know um if we if we hooked up with
somebody we had a high chance of getting
pregnant so we would take a lot more
time to make sure that person like vet
that per that guy make sure he's
actually interested and he can actually
like help you with the family he'll be
there stay around for the kid
nowadays we have birth control that
takes away the consequence so women can
sleep around with no consequences we
take away that like part of biology
that makes sense yeah so so now that
even a smaller percentage of men get
access to more and more women where the
rest of the men
get access to none
well arguably the consequence has just
shifted
that now that women obviously you know
sleep around whatever yeah you the
consequence of that is that it's
near
impossible to get commitment from the
men that you truly desire
yeah that's true yeah that's a good
point yeah